un bonsoir monaco lé la situation
la situation est bien regarder juste
derrière moi stéphanie plusieurs
centaines d'hommes de femmes d'enfants
se sont installés sur cette place de la
république ils sont arrivés aux
alentours de 18h30 la présence policière
est plus tôt
discrète contrairement à l'action qu'il
ya eu en novembre 2020 alors justement
pour en parler je suis avec philippe
carraud et c'est un bénévole
bonsoir à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france
alors on l'a vu plusieurs centaines de
personnes sont installées ici quel est
le but de cette occupation ici la place
de la république dès ce soir c'est la
nuit de la solidarité et
nous le constat qu'on fait quand même
depuis des mois depuis au moins un an de
pandémie humaine même avancé qu' il ya
énormément de gens dans les rues et qui
en a de plus en plus on distribue pour
vous donner une idée ce soir il ya une
maraude de notre collectif alimentaire
on va distribuer à peu près 900 repas
mardi on a distribué à peu près 900
repas sauf que depuis novembre
il ya une chasse à l'homme dans les rues
de paris et qui fait que les gens qui
essaient de se poser quand ils sont un
peu trop visibles sont chassés nous ce
qu'on voit dans nos maraudes c'est qu'il
ya des centaines et des centaines de
personnes mais c'est invisible alors
qu'un campement où c'était plus visible
est ce qu'on rend visible ce soir c'est
justement ça les invisibles ce soir on
rend visible et invisible qu'elle est
quel est le profil de ces migrants de
ces personnes qui sont présentes ici
alors il ya plusieurs profils puisque ce
soir ça
un collectif réquisitions qui à
l'initiative de sacs qui est proposé en
fait de plusieurs associations et
collectifs
donc nous solidarité migrants wilson
mais aussi le dal qui dit qui y est
plutôt sur les
les mal logés et les sans le sans
domicile fixe à et aussi utopia 56 et
aussi enfants d'afghanistan est
d'ailleurs voilà plusieurs années d'exil
plusieurs associations qui ont des
publics
très différents mais quand même un point
commun c'est qu'on trouve beaucoup
beaucoup de gens nous les uns et les
autres à la rue donc on a décidé d'unir
nos forces pour demander une chose
simple c'est l'application de la loi la
loi de réquisition c'est à dire qu'en
france il ya une loi qui permet aux
préfets
à l'état en fait de réquisitionner des
logements vides et on a plus de cent
mille appareils 313 milles et voyez il
ya quand même quelques centaines de
personnes donc en gros
on pourrait relever immédiatement ces
gens m'ont allemand on a déposé en
décembre 412
demande de réquisition pas une seule à
bouger donc on a occupé une école dans
le 16e arrondissement en janvier qu'a
permis de mettre à l'abri 160 170
personnes en février on a occupé l'hôtel
dieu qui a permis de mettre à l'abri en
plein plan grand froid 70 personnes qui
se qualifie ce cas qui auraient dormi à
la rue ce soir là par leurs enfants
et donc on continue ses actions là
jusqu'à ce que
la loi de réquisition soit appliquée car
en quelques années le but de cette de
cette occupation est ce que ça de rester
toute la nuit c'est de perdurer ici sur
cette place de la république
alors ya une partie de l'équation qui
dépend pas de nous c'est à dire que nous
ici d'avoir s'est quand même fait en
lien avec des extraits des réfugiés les
gens qui dorment dans la rue donc toute
façon s'ils n'ont pas ici ils vont aller
ailleurs dormir dans la rue dr gros ce
qu'on demande nous c'est que ce soir dès
ce soir
il ya une solution pérenne et puis aussi
qui peut qui peut être l'application de
la loi de réquisition tout simplement
donc après le camp jeudi une partie de
l'équation qui ne dépend pas de nous
c'est nous si les pouvoirs publics en
gros trouver une solution ce soir il ya
plus personne ce soir ici s'y trouvent
pas de solution nous on va rester enfin
voilà est-ce que vous craignez
l'intervention des forces de l'ordre on
se souvient notamment de novembre 2020
où il ya eu une évacuation à ses muscles
et il va les brutalités cesse les
brutalités des forces de l'ordre
vis-à-vis des exilés notamment c'est pas
une nouveauté c'est ce que les médias
ont vu en novembre parce que ça a été ça
s'est fait ici c'est un sujet plus monde
nous c'est ce qu'on constate quand même
depuis des années et c'est ce qu'on voit
d'ailleurs depuis
après voilà ce soir il ya du monde il ya
au moins 300 ans
je pense à peu près de 300 400 personnes
il ya plein de gens qui filme il ya des
médias qui sont là et on pense que ils
ont quand même compris la leçon qu'ils
ont eue en novembre de là
dernière et que
en haut on
ils seront peut-être plus disposés à
trouver des solutions durables et
pérennes
voilà mais nous ce qu'on veut c'est
quand même la loi l'application de la
loi de réquisition
merci beaucoup aux philippe carraud pour
ce témoignage
vous l'avez entendu stéphanie pour le
moment tout va dépendre de comment va se
dérouler la nuit est pour l'instant
contrairement à l'action dupont qui
avait eu lieu en novembre 2020 et bien
la présence policière elle est très
timide très discrète puisqu'en novembre
2020 toute cette place est bien elle
était encerclée par les forces de
l'ordre
ce soir c'est différent l'ambiance est
plus plus plus disons plus bon enfant
regarder juste derrière moi il y à un
orchestre qui joue de la musique
plusieurs passants s'arrêtent notamment
pour discuter avec ces migrants avec qui
sont qui parmi eux il ya des enfants des
femmes qui sont juste ici alors vous
l'avez vu tout dépendra de comment va se
dérouler cette soirée ici en tout cas
ils comptent rester sur cette place de
la république toute la nuit les mercis
mohamud et laure accompagné de
lucas tu as pour les images en direct de
la place de la république à paris